thank you
[Applause]
I I will say this
I mean my people can attest because many
of my people were here from the
beginning we've never had a level of
spirit that we have right now and that's
because people really see the country as
as being we're like at a Crossroads and
I used to say if we keep it going like
this we're going to be Venezuela on
steroids and that's what it's going to
be and that's where we're heading and so
many people see that I appreciate that
very much yes ma'am
uh we're going to do we're going to work
on that you're right about that isn't
that a disgrace ESG ESG at the bank so
we'll take care of those Banks yes ma'am
please go ahead
[Music]
yeah yeah
uh thank you thank you how nice is that
huh are you related are you related
daughter that's beautiful beautiful
that's a beautiful that's a great job I
could not have said it that well that I
can tell you uh we're doing a lot for
the disabled we're doing a lot for
everybody it's beautifully put too thank
you very much darling thank you okay a
couple of more go ahead please
[Applause]
thank you
and I don't have to
assessments the number one victim of
January 6th so he goes back to November
yeah
[Applause]
looks very nice I I feel that I feel
that but you know uh some people Ashley
Babbitt lost their lives so when you
think about it I would say that's you
know they're the they're the number
people lose their lives and they're the
number one victims but no I certainly
feel that too but uh I appreciate that
statement they come after me and the
better I do the more they come after me
you know because they don't want us to
we had a poll in Florida we're just
absolutely killing killing Biden by much
more than the other one the other one is
not doing as well by even close uh we're
beating every primary opponent by so
much including number two and we have to
do that
somebody said why don't you be nicer
they say because we have to win we have
to win we have to win this it's not a
game we're trying to save our country
and if we don't save our country I I
think if we don't I think it's the most
important election we've ever had
because it's like our country's decaying
from within you have a question Go
please
young lady okay I'll do both
the one with beautiful brown hair and
beautiful brunt blonde hair go ahead
same question okay
executive orders first
step and you're right moms how about
where they talk about parental they want
parental power parental rights who would
ever think you would have to talk about
it today parental is a word it's a big
powerful word because they took our
education away from the mothers and the
fathers who love the children so much
even from the teachers to a certain
extent but and they have it in in these
people's hands between men participating
in women's sports which is so ridiculous
and so many things that are far worse
than that
far worse than that you know what I'm
talking about so uh we're going to take
care of that very quickly it's going to
have we as you know we took care of it
when I was there but and they they added
a thing called the military into it too
that's uh pretty incredible yes please
go ahead
I think about it a little bit but I
don't like to think about it too much we
have vice president that saying have you
put any thought I think about it we have
a lot of candidates right we have them
running left and right but uh I think
about it but I don't want to think about
it too much one thing I will say
nobody's ever voted for a vice president
meaning when you're running for
president if you have one that's uh
great or one that's a little bit less
than grade or if you have one that's bad
yeah bad ones too uh it really doesn't
have too many this one is
now it's uh
might be the best thing he's got going
right
but uh you know it's a little bit of an
old Axiom that nobody ever votes for the
vice president and uh I think you know
I'd give it more credit than that it's
still a very it's so important because
something happens and you you have
yourself a president so it's very
important but I don't think from a
voting standpoint uh it matters uh very
much yes please
here
campaign
yes
Patrick
this morning instead of saying I love
you Mom and Dad good morning
and he wanted us to say that he is a
soldier ready to serve under you
um
say hello give me a big kiss okay
that's that's very nice thank you thank
you very much please go ahead
um
[Music]
well we have very strong laws uh and you
know if you look at Chicago where last
weekend I don't know if you saw that 50
people were shot 12 died they have the
strongest gun laws in the country New
York likewise Los Angeles likewise
they're all the strongest gun laws
that's where the the biggest problems
are no I'm a guardian of the Second
Amendment as you know I didn't let him
do anything to it and uh very strong
gravity yeah
go ahead
[Applause]
yeah I said six months he wants me to do
it in six weeks we could I'll tell you
what but even in six even in six weeks
we can make a hell of a dent right
drill drill baby
now we can actually I might change it if
you think about it in six weeks we can
make a hell of a dent yeah I said six
months
I also said that uh I believe I can end
the war
between Russia and Ukraine I know
zelinski very well and I know Putin very
well
I believe I can end it in 24 hours and
that's what should happen
okay good
okay uh this young handsome man right
here go two of them
hi
makeup
well the American dream you don't hear
about it anymore
right now there is no American Dream you
know it used to be the American dream
today you don't hear about it uh what we
do is we have to free it up we have to
have great elections we have to have
strong borders we have to have
incentives to get people to want to be
entrepreneurs or to work or to work for
a living I mean it's great
and
we'll we can get back here if we don't
win this upcoming election because we
still have a long way to go you know we
still have a long way you know the
damage they can do in a little more than
a year and a half is is incredible look
at what look at the damage they've done
during this period of time nobody thinks
it's possible nobody would have believed
it's possible but if we get in we're
gonna we're gonna make a lot of American
Dreams happen just like we've just like
we did we were doing so well I told the
story today to one of the groups I met
with a lot of different groups and this
one was very important to a man but I
told the story today I was so so crazy
we have to get in we have to create
incentive for people to want to go to
work you know a lot of the people that
had jobs refused to work now that I
don't know they got used to not working
we have to create incentive for them to
get back we have to get back and they
don't want to work and they don't show
it as a job opening they say oh we have
three and a half that's false it's false
information but we have to create I mean
the American dream it's a it's a great
question because I don't you don't hear
that expression anymore the American
dream but you guys are young you're
gonna very soon you're gonna see the
American dream back okay good thank you
[Applause]
he did
he just fell on what stage
he's at the Air Force Academy
he actually fell down
well I hope he wasn't hurt I hope he
wasn't hurt but it's the whole thing is
look the whole thing is crazy
you got to be careful about that you got
to be careful about that because you
don't you don't want that even if you
have to tip toe down a ramp you gotta
it's like an ice cube you know it's a
safe because that was the best speech I
think I've ever made
and it was pouring rain and it was
horrible and cold and windy and they
have a ramp that was pure like an ice
skating rink and it was like 25 feet
long and I talking to the general and he
has boots on you know big combat boots
in their rubber soles and I have nice
leather good
and uh I say you know what general get
ready if I grab you you just get ready
because I got this stupid ramp that
somebody put up and there's no stairs
right and I said so I tiptoed down and I
suffered for that they never covered my
speech but everybody the smart people
understood that but uh that's too bad if
you felt it's too bad look it's just
yeah the winds
look you know we gotta we gotta just get
this thing back on track that's a that's
a bad place to fall when you're making
uh I think it was the Air Force Academy
right he's making that's not inspiring
go ahead
yeah well you know everybody wanted a
vaccine at that time and I was able to
do something that nobody else could have
done getting it done very very rapidly
but I never was for mandates I was I
thought the mandates were terrible
and
and you know there's a big portion of
the country that thinks that was a great
thing you understand that not a lot of
the people in this room but there's a
big but there is a big portion I had a
man come up to me the other day who's
actually a Democrat liberal guy a friend
of mine and he said to me uh I don't
even know if he voted for me to be
honest but he's a friend of mine smart
guy and but very liberal he said why is
it you never mention what you did with
the vaccines I said no thanks I'm not
going to be doing that right now but uh
you know there is a big he said it's
amazing you save so many lives there's a
big portion that feel very much the
opposite we can understand that we can
we can handle that but uh I I hated the
idea of the mandates and I didn't do the
mandates you know I didn't make any
Governor close their state Florida did
close as you know but South Carolina uh
North South Dakota a lot of States
didn't Tennessee a lot of states the
governors really did a good job Iowa
didn't really close and
and they they really didn't go in
Florida you know that that state was
locked down he didn't even want people
to drive in the highways but close to
all the beaches close to heat that state
was locked down for a period of time and
I'm not saying anything good bad or
indifferent but there were states that
did no lockdown and I gave Governors the
right to do that now all the governors
closed down they locked down very hard
all the the Democrat Governors but
numerous of the Republican Governors
didn't and I gave them that option it's
called The Federalist system and you
know some took advantage because I
didn't say you have to lock down what I
said is you make your own decision but
we had numerous Republican Governors
that did a fantastic job that didn't
lock down and uh they really did we had
some we had some great Governors I would
say that there were no Democrat
Governors that did that they were all
for the lockdowns and you know they they
suffered a they suffered a very big
price for that that was really bad what
it did to the children what it did to a
lot of people and and they uh they hurt
a lot of people with those lockdowns
those lockdowns were bad but no no
mandates on that the mandates were bad
the mandates were very prevalent in some
states uh if you look back by the way if
you look back at Florida they had a big
vaccine program I want to tell you you
get vaccine you just get vaccinated you
know it's amazing how people forget all
of a sudden they forget
but uh I'm very proud of a lot of our
Governors they did really a fantastic
job they really did a fantastic job and
this state is one of them they did a
really great job yes ma'am go ahead
very nice
we sent a lot of effort and money and
everything else on that that's right
I also want
someone yeah
good
um
gotten worse than having human
trafficking
thank you thank you
well I can end with a nicer statement
than that that was a statement not a
question
uh thank you very much
we love you all thank you very much
thank you very much really good thank
you
thank you
we got a win we gotta win big thank you
foreign
thank you everybody
don't eat too much pizza
have a good time thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
foreign